It is great to welcome to the program today.
Phil Gursky, who's a 30 year Canadian intelligence
veteran, author of five books on terrorism
and also host of the podcast and intelligent
look at Terrorism.
Phil, it's great to have you on today.
Hey, it's great to be here, David.
Thanks for inviting me on the show.
So, I mean, where to start, right?
I guess the war on terror has now been waged
for decades.
How is it going?
Are we winning it yet?
No, we're not.
And, you know, you referenced the fact that
I've written five books.
My fourth book was actually entitled An End
to the War on Terrorism.
I hate the term.
I've hated it since day one.
As you noted in your introduction, I work
in security intelligence for that.
So for the Canadian security intelligence
service, kind of like an FBI, CIA hybrid,
we looked at homegrown plots, Canadians traveling
to join al-Qaeda later, ISIS, et cetera.
Al-Shabaab in Somalia.
And yet we're framing this through the military.
And the problem is as as American academic
said very wisely after 9/11, he says whatever
you do, don't declare war on a common now
because it never ends.
Think of the war on drugs in your country.
You think of the war on poverty.
You think on the war on any common man, because
you said common nouns don't surrender, whereas
proper nouns do.
So you asked me, how's it going?
It's going well and not so well.
Well, in a sense that in your country and
mine, we're not seeing terrorist attacks on
a regular basis.
Let's face it, that's that's true.
And yet, if you look at the news on any given
day, David, which I do as a as a regular course,
you know, I'm retired.
I'm still involved in this business every
day in Afghanistan, Somalia or Nigeria or
Iraq or Syria.
There's an attack and several cases, many
attacks per day in those countries.
So it's going both well and not so well, depending
on your perspective, I guess, here in the
United States.
There is an interesting report from the Anti
Defamation League, which I've referenced before,
which looked at a politically based domestic
terror killings, so to speak.
And they are overwhelmingly right wing.
The numbers, as I recall, I think in twenty
nineteen were 76 percent right wing, 20 percent
Islamic extremism, and then four percent left
or sort of miscellaneous.
Now, from a logistical perspective, when I
hear that someone believes their religion
should be the law of the land and is willing
to kill for those reasons.
To me, that sounds right wing.
So when I think of Islamic extremism, it's
often framed as left wing.
It sounds really right wing to me in the intelligence
community.
Is there a position on that, on the characterization
of Islamic violence?
Wow, I've never thought of it in that term
before.
We've certainly looked at Islamist extremism
as our number one threat.
We had several plots in the 2000s and 2010s.
Several Hunter Canadians want to join ISIS,
et cetera, et cetera.
We had a small right wing desk, which frankly
wasn't very busy.
When I retired in 2015, I'm sure it's busier
right now.
I would push back a little bit on the stats.
It's true that in your country, obviously,
the far right is about two thirds or three
quarters of the incidents around the world
is still 95 percent Islamist extremism.
If you look at the numbers across the world,
no denial whatsoever.
Yeah, yeah.
The way you framed it is really interesting.
So I did write a book.
My last book was entitled When Religions Kill.
And I looked at how every religion has within
it an extreme element that justifies killing
in the name of God, Judaism, Christianity,
even Buddhism.
My God.
Buddhist extremists should be an oxymoron.
And yet there are Buddhist terrorists in Sri
Lanka, in Thailand and Myanmar.
I guess you would say that Islamist extremists
are conservative.
They're definitely very intolerant.
The view of Islam that they try to force on
people is exclusionary.
Essentially, it's my way or the highway.
Bernard Lewis, the American academic academic,
said very famously after 9/11, it's like it's
I'm right.
You're wrong.
Go to hell.
That's the way these people see the world.
So I guess some perspective.
We would look at it as right wing.
But from my experience working in a case in
Intelligence Committee, it was its own separate
task and it was the lion's share of the counterterrorism
work for the better part of the 20 years you
just referred to in the post 9/11 period.
When we think about the radicalization of
individuals, when I've interviewed domestic
extremists in the United States like former
KKK and white nationalists and others almost
exclusively, there is a story of there was
a lack of empathy and support in their lives
which led them vulnerable to sort of join
up with whoever paid them attention and accept
the orthodoxy that they presented in in international
terror and the work that you did.
Is it a similar pattern?
What leads to the radicalization of an individual?
Wow.
How much time do we have?
I mean, my very first book, The Threat, from
what they looked at it and I was based on
key cases, I worked in Canada.
Unclassified information, obviously.
But we found the opposite, David.
We found that these people were run of the
mill average Canadians.
They were average from a socio economic status.
They were average from an educational background.
They were average from a family background.
They were average, insofar as we could tell.
We're not psychologists from a mental health
perspective.
There was nothing that sort of divided them
or separated them from the general Canadian
populace.
And I've seen the same stats for the United
States as well in terms of ism extremism.
I do think that we look at the far right KKK.
You know, the boogaloo boys, you might see
that kind of a bit of a tendency towards the
down and out in life.
You know, you often hear the term marginalized.
You hear the term not making ends meet, you
know, failing and education, failing at relationships,
failing at that work.
We'll see you down in the ISM aside.
But, of course, you have exceptions.
You look at a country like France.
Yeah.
And a lot of the people who join ISIS and
al-Qaida in France are on the lower socio
economic spectrum.
But I would argue you look at French Muslim
society in general and it's generally speaking,
gets on the lower.
You know, your country and my country are
very different.
Muslims in our country have tend to tend to
do very, very well.
They tend to be highly educated.
They tend to be have good jobs, solid families,
et cetera.
In Europe, that's not the case for all kinds
of historical reasons.
Bottom line, David, is that there's no profit
profile to any of this.
And people that try to profile get into trouble
because we're trying to profile.
You run into two problems.
Yes.
One's what to call a false positive.
If you think that all jihadis are all right
wing guys are X and somebodies is X and is
not a jihadi.
That's a problem.
And then if you say that no jihadis are well
educated or no KKK or well-educated, the first
guy with a PD you don't look at because he
doesn't fit your your profile.
So when we were at work that can skirt intelligence
service, we didn't have a profile.
We looked at activity.
We looked at, you know, online statements
which we had warrants to intercept.
We looked at what they said and what they
did, not who they were, where they came from
or what their particular circumstances were.
And I think that was a that was successful
for us when it comes to the leaders of terrorist
organizations over the last 20 years.
We've all seen endless headlines of the number
two was killed, the number three.
You know what?
Whatever how how how important is that to
actually fighting terror?
And I'll make the question sort of a two part
question.
One, if what we're fighting is an ideology,
is the ideology affected by killing an individual?
Is it sometimes?
Sometimes yes, sometimes no.
OK, and then number two, even from the operational
standpoint, how effective is it to kill the
number one, the number two, the number three
guy?
I'm going to give you an answer.
I'm going to like it depends.
OK, so.
So in some groups, it's all about the leader
of a group like Shining Path.
So that'll do it also in Peru.
When Guzman was taken by the Peruvians back
in the early 90s, the group never really recovered.
They're still around, but they're a shadow
of their former selves.
You look at al-Qaida.
Bin Laden is gone now.
Ayman al-Zawahiri can't hold a candle to bin
Laden.
For my current charismatic perspective, he's
the he's like watching paint dry.
And, you know, al-Qaida is still around.
We've got Baghdadi, right, a couple of years.
You guys got Baghdadi.
ISIS is just a stronger force trauma than
it ever was.
I better cases maybe the PKK in Turkey, the
Kurdish militant group.
The Turks count Capstick Abdullah oculi back
in 1994.
He's been in prison on an island near Turkey
for the better part of over 20 years.
The cake, the PKK is carrying out attacks
on a weekly basis in eastern Turkey.
So the short answer is it depends on the nature
of the group and the control of what the leader
has against within that group.
The second part of your question is, look,
it's never a bad thing to take out a major
terrorist.
We always used to say a dead terrorist is
a good terrorist.
You don't have to investigate them anymore.
You don't worry about him.
He can't exert his influence, et cetera, et
cetera.
Now, we can argue about rule of law and whether
or not extraterritorial assassinations are
legal.
That's a whole other discussion.
So taking guys out is never a bad thing.
The problem is it rarely, if ever, means the
end.
And I'm I'm tired of reading headlines.
You know, we've got so and so this is the
end of group number X, X, Y or Z.
It never is or very rarely is, because, as
you mentioned, is the ideology that's important,
not the individual.
The individual can be charismatic, attract
people, retain people, inspire people.
But charismatic people are sometimes a dime
a dozen.
It's the ideology that matters.
That's what you have to undermine.
And that's a lot more difficult to carry.
You can't cure a drone strike.
It gets an ideology, unfortunately.
I want to get back to that.
But because you mentioned, you know, the question
as to the legality of extraterritorial killings
of suspected terrorists in the work you did.
Did that play at all in in your work or is
that sort of like that was handled?
The legal questions were are handled somewhere
else?
Absolutely.
So we're we're essentially we were certainly
a domestic intelligence service, but we had
an international remit because Canadians were
fighting with the Taliban and al-Qaida, things
like that.
We had lawyers, obviously, that were able
to guide us.
But we follow the law in a sense that we went
to court to get warrants to intercept people
communications.
You have to do that.
You can't you don't follow somebody out on
Twitter or intercept it because that's your
legal in Canada.
So from our perspective, we provided intelligence
and you provided to decision makers.
Now, sometimes the decision makers by be in
the Canadian military or the U.S. military,
and they will decide to do with that intelligence,
whatever that their mandate says that they
can do.
I didn't lose sleep at night personally about
my intelligence being used in a way that I
might not necessarily agree with for my own
ethical perspective, because, first of all,
a cat has a pretty small player, right?
We're not carrying out drone strikes that
you guys are in Yemen and Afghanistan and
Somalia.
So if my perspective wasn't as important,
I do think there's a bigger conversation around
this.
And I know that when Entry-Level Awlaki, who
is the American who was killed in Yemen a
couple of years ago, that raised a real kerfuffle
at your country because he was an American
citizen and didn't get his day in court.
Right.
He was to to refute the charges against them.
I didn't lose sleep over Awlaki because he
was a major instigator.
He was a major charismatic leader of al-Qaida
in the Arabian Peninsula.
There wasn't a single Canadia that didn't
follow his writings or his videos online.
So he had disappeared.
It was it was a good, good news day for us.
But on the other side of the coin, I do understand
the legal ramifications of it.
But when you work in intelligence, you provide
the best information you can to those that
can use it.
And you do so to the best of your ability.
OK.
So now that that being kind of framed in terms
of your work, when we think about what does
work to root out an ideology, I mean, is it
one?
One area that doesn't seem to be discussed
enough is sort of the economic situation in
the source countries.
And when we talk about undocumented immigration
here in the United States, you know, the current
administration talks about walls and they
talk about, you know, jail and all this stuff.
If the economic circumstances were better
in the source countries, the demand for trying
to come to the United States illegally would
decrease dramatically.
Ken, does that apply to thinking about the
ideologies that rise and the way in which
people can be injured?
Dr. Unaided, can that be separated from the
context in which these countries are existing?
You're asking really tough questions for me
on Canada Day.
That's a tough one.
Again, it depends, because if you look at
9/11, for example, 15 of the 19 hijackers
that attacked New York and Washington were
rich Saudi individuals.
They didn't have any socio economic problems.
I do think that it obviously makes sense from
a humanitarian and global stability perspective
to make sure that every country is as economically
feasible and workable as as possible.
And yes, it might, in fact.
Prevent or convince people to stay at home
rather than come to Cadie, United States.
I mean, you know, we take in one percent of
our population every year by immigration.
We did get three or a thousand people a year.
So it's it's one percent.
Your country has a similar high rate.
It did.
The current president, maybe not so much.
So I think that put it this way, David.
It can't hurt.
But I'm not necessarily certain that it would
be enough to undermine the ideology.
The ideology has to be undermined by the vast
majority of people who live in that greater
polity, be it Islam or Buddhism or Hinduism
or Judaism, whatever, who fight against it,
who say this is not what we represent.
This is not what our faith tells us to do.
This is not what the founders of our religion
said is a good thing to do.
It's only those people that can say this is
wrong.
We're not going to support it.
And we're going to actively undermine what
you're trying to do.
That to me.
And I've seen it happen here in Canada on
a limited scale.
That, to me is the only way we're going to
say you'll get rid of the Islamist extremist
ideology or the Hindu extremist ideology in
India, which is very worrisome, by the way,
these days with what Modi is doing with his
support from very violent Hindu extremists
in the RSS, in other parts of Indian society.
Those are people that have to stand up with
our support and basically talk down and get
rid of the ideology that is being spewed by
a very small minority within their communities.
That's not that's not exaggerate this.
Right.
Very, very few people espouses ideology.
That's why I mean, that's why when I hear
you saying it has to be made clear by everybody
else that this is not acceptable.
It seems that that's already sort of the case.
Right?
I mean, I guess I would.
What you're saying sounds so intuitive, and
yet it starts to sound sort of like, you know,
where where are all of the moderate Muslims
denouncing this?
And it's like, well, they they are right.
I mean, it's so.
So it starts to get into sort of dicey territory
because you're already talking about such
a small portion of the poppy of any population.
Well, I would also counter that you're not
going to get rid of his ideology.
It's not going to disappear tomorrow.
I mean, communism was we fought against.
I started my career in the Cold War in nineteen
eighty three.
There's all Soviet Union is Soviet Union that
that founded.
And yet look what's happening now in modern
Russia.
You could argue it's a resurgence of the communist
ideal or whatever you want to call it.
So they the ideology is not going to vanish
poof one day into the ether.
It's always going to be there.
What you're trying to do is to make it such
that it's an irritant, not an all encompassing
sort of.
I don't know that this obsession you have,
it's all terrorism all the time.
But it's you know, it's not all terrorism
all the time in my country.
I am actually researching a book on the history
of terrorism in Canada from Confederation,
which is one hundred, fifty three years ago
today.
You know, we've suffered at most 20 attacks
in one hundred and fifty three years.
Now, mind you, we went a century between attack
one and attack two.
We get my point right.
We're not Afghanistan.
We're not Somalia.
We're not Nigeria.
We're not Yemen.
Down to neither is your country.
Neither are most countries in Western Europe.
So how can we get away from this obsession
about terrorism?
Let our counterterrorism agencies do their
jobs as well as law enforcement, get citizen
reinvolved to talk these guys down to two,
either ignore them or to counter their views.
But let's not think that we're over suddenly,
existentially threatened by terror.
This is not makes sense.
All right, David.
It is.
If you're if you're for an Afghan, it's not
if you're an American and it's not if you're
a Canadian.
We've been speaking with Phil Gursky, who's
a 30 plus year Canadian intelligence veteran,
author of five books on terrorism.
Also hosts the podcast, An Intelligent Look
at Terrorism.
Phil, I so appreciate your time today.
My pleasure.
Dave, us to be able you again sometime.